I was in New Jersey I was in Atlantic
City one more time one more again I
didn't want to be in Atlantic City of
course because Atlantic City because
it's Atlantic
City H I had to go back because I
thought I was done with the movie and
they were like hey you got to come to do
a body scan for visual effects and I go
like
this
what I said is this a prank I thought it
was a prank and they're like they she
writes back
negative oh we're getting oh we're
getting official dude you're going to
write negative in an
email oh we're getting all businesslike
all of a sudden because because I think
it's a prank we're getting business like
she writes negative we need you out here
to do the VFX scan and then she started
sounding like Charlie Brown's teacher do
you know why because all I could hear
was my
blood I was so mad I heard my blood you
ever get so mad you hear your blood
that's that's what I was doing sizzling
that's what I heard I go like this is
somebody cooking
bacon and
uh so I did
that and um and I was like well let's
let's [__] and they we're like we got
to come
Sunday this is how I do let me a little
taste of me
okay I come here Sunday I I they like we
we want to fly at 10:00 a.m. Sunday
we'll do the VFX scan Monday morning and
then you can leave Monday night so I go
like
this I'll take the red eye I'll take the
red eye I'll land in Philly drive to AC
get there by around 7 a.m. do the VFX
scan and then I'm leaving first flight
out and they go like this okay well we
might need you until 3:30 and I go like
this K I'll take the 330 flight even
though there's a 1250 flight they
thought I wouldn't make it so me old
Chris good sport deia flies over their
red eyee did I sleep a wink no why even
In First Class why couldn't I do it
because I can't sleep on planes because
it was also the [__] first class
where like the seats are only a little
bit di bigger not diver cuz it's not a
word but I said diver and I don't know
why I I mean bigger so the seats were a
little bit diver and so I didn't so I
got there drove 7 a.m. got there no
one's there to receive me I don't know
where to go so I go like this where the
[__] do I
go snapped at an ad a little bit was
probably pretty shitty didn't mean to
wasn't his fault but you know what I've
been flying all night I apologized to
him later all good and I feel bad even
still cuz I like that guy he's got a
really kind face and he was really nice
and one of the guys that I connected
with
anyway
um do the VFX scan get all dressed in my
[__] gear and you know 20 minutes
fine then I I'm done by nine and I go
like this I can make the 1250 flight so
I get in touch with the travel agent for
production and I say
hey can I uh can I get the 1250
flight now mind you I've had no sleep I
email a manager Josh liberman yeah you
know won't find a flight you know if
there's a seat on there there seat on
the plane right soone get it right
that's what he's saying so I'm like all
right cool so try to do it okay so he
says okay so I'm like you know I'm going
to set my alarm I'm going to go to sleep
I'm going wake up in an hour I'll check
and see if the flight's changed I wake
up flight's not changed all good at this
point I'm Dreaming man at this point
trolls are bringing me Bagels right I'm
in my head I'm out on [__] La La Land
I'm hanging out with the kebler El
somewhere
okay so I emailed Josh and I said listen
Josh is probably too late and I emailed
the travel agent don't change the flight
I'll just go at 3:30 because I'm going
to [__] drift and and [__] chill
with these keer elves and L La Land a
little bit longer and I'll just fly out
my day shot anyway and Josh says look
you're going to dream keep in there like
okay so I said
great cut
two the ad knocks on my door and it's
12:25 and she says hey you got to get up
because your rides here for the 3:30
flight and I say great ready to go
okay so I go downstairs and as I'm going
downstairs in the elevator
FL I have an email so I checked email
and it's from Lo behold the travel agent
and she says switched your flight to
[Music]
it's
12:25 now I wouldn't have been able to
make that flight if I was at the airport
already
however I'm on I'm getting into the car
to go to the
airport and I'm in Atlantic City and the
airport I'm flying out
[Music]
of is in
Philadelphia now I'm reading this email
and good thing nobody's telling it to me
because all I can hear is my
blood
I'm smelling around for
Bacons now one time when I was in linat
I used to go to this place that would
have the bombass turkey uh tuna they
would have the bombass tuna melts and it
was called burgies and it's still there
because they make the bombass tuna melts
and whenever I was in linat to visiting
my mom I would get the bombass tuna
melts and one time a kid named Colin
Barnes told me to get bacon on the tuna
melt and I was like what why would you
[__] something perfect up that's like
eating cheese while you're getting your
dick sucked sure I like both of those
things but separately is better okay and
Colin goes like this just try
it and I say all right so I walk up to
the counter and I say hey uh can I get
bacon on my tuna melt and the guy behind
the counter says how many bacons
and I think of that every three
weeks so now I'm in the car
okay and I call Josh and he says look I
got the email you look I got the email I
see there's a s in
there so I say yeah just make sure that
I'm still on the 3 flight because I just
got the itinerary that my flight changed
in 20
minutes all right but I think secretly
I'm looking at it wrong when I see this
email I think oh I have to go to the
doctor because I have a tumor pushing up
against my optical
nerve cuz it's scrambling what I'm
looking at I'm looking at 330 but it
looks like like
1250 so I hang up the
phone and then Josh calls me back oh
they made
mistake and so I made 50 how far me from
the airport and I say it's in
Philly I'm not in Philly I'm just
checking I'm I'm your I'm your side
you so I say okay well make sure she
changes it back to
3:30 cuz I'm on my way now and I don't
want to get to the
airport
happen gonna happen all right so so then
he calls me back and he says I I just
got off I screaming with them okay I
like we got your ticket but it's not
first class anymore they lost the
seat and everything else was like that
scene in Private Ryan when the guy's
looking for his arm and you just
here and I'm
just and I'm looking for my itinerary I
can't find I'm looking for my itinerary
like he's looking for his arm I'm just
[Music]
like getting my water
bot and all a sudden it comes
back in there you know I'll call him but
it'll be in there and I
click dude
I get to the airport and I'm in seat
like
4,355 Z I didn't even know the plane
went that far by the time I got to the
back of the plane I was already in Los
[Music]
Angeles so I'm furious there's nothing I
can
do I get to the gate the guy I want to
pull this [__] he said I said say yeah I
was supposed to be in first they lost
the thing and then the thing happened
and then and he goes like this well I
it's full sorry if you want to go first
though there's another flight uh the
only one left where there's F first is
900 p.m. and I go like this hey man it's
[__] 1:00 what am I going to do at
the airport in Philly for8 hours how
many times am I going to [__] lap
Hudson
News you know what I mean like [__]
goddamn Hudson News have you ever seen a
Hudson News out of the airport what the
[__] get it together dude go outside
Hudson
News so I [__] get on the pl I'm I'm
dude I'm hearing bacon Sizzle I'm
hearing how many Bacons Sizzle dude I
don't even know how many Bacons is are
sizzling in my [__] head right now in
my ears so I get to the [__]
plane and just to make matters worse in
first first they got the lay down beds
dude but here Daddy is all propped up
like a goddamn praying
mantis I bought even bought one of those
[__] neck pillow things I'm propped
up like a PR like I'm [__] Steven
Hawking just praying praying mantis and
the [__] video doesn't even work the
[__] back of the seat video so I'm
just guess what I'm doing for five hours
thinking
I know these are [__] rich guy
problems but I don't give a sh dude
here's the other thing this was this
Twist of the knife I'm talking to one of
the cast members and they say you didn't
do the VFX thing in Albuquerque they had
it there for two
[Laughter]
months I flew there
for I'm a
businessman and you know how Jay-Z is
like I'm not a businessman I'm a
businessman I'm just a businessman
okay make no mistake I'm not a
businessman I'm a
businessman so that was my [__] holy
[__] my Topsy Turvy Adventure I was in
Atlantic City for [__] 6 hours 10
hours there 10 hours back including the
drive time even more
probably anyway dude let's pay some
bills